where'd you go sorry get your head in
the game seriously miss city was about
to blow up no one realized I wasn't here
where did you go I went to earth to had
to talk to Jessie hear from her she told
me she needs to focus on herself and I
get it and I think I have to do the same
right so I'm leaving central see where
where are you going I'm gonna go stay
with a friend in Blue Valley for a while
every hero has their own journey fair
just taking you on a new path do it to
yourself to go hey everybody what's
going on you asked me for a new Titans
video because supposedly we're going to
be getting Roy Harper on that I'll
explain a little bit about the logistics
because they're filming that in Toronto
in Colton Haynes is coming back to arrow
this season so there's like a lot of Roy
Harper stuff happening on TV in what's
going on with Wally West because he just
left the flash they're also doing a
little bit of retooling with the way
they handled multiple speedsters if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's flash ring giveaway stuff that
I'll explain at the end of the video too
so they already have Nightwing Beast Boy
Raven Starfire Hawk dove and then a
couple more minor police characters from
the Chuck Dixon Nightwing rung because
it's gonna be sort of the era that the
TV show set in so the Roy Harper
description reads male age 17 to 19
Caucasian athletic street-smart cocky
yet charming his life has changed
forever when he crosses a crime fighter
and has given a new outlet for his
rebellious ways recurring guest star so
when it says recurring guest star just
means that he's not going to be in every
single episode maybe like three or four
episodes out of 13 total so naturally
that description reads exactly like Roy
Harper's back story in the comics they
even did the exact same version of that
for Colton Haynes arrow character but
the thing is is that even if they do get
Roy Harper it sounds like they're gonna
recast the role and it'll be somebody
different so this sort of confirms that
this is happening on a different earth
in the multiverse meaning that you'll
probably see characters that
you've already seen on arrow but
there'll be different actors playing
them and that'll sort of explain why
it's not the exact same person but I
think part of the reason for not going
with Colton Haynes is one he would have
had to sign on to the series he's been
doing a lot of American Horror Story
stuff he's been doing a lot of movies
and you can't do that when you do a lot
of television shows for most of the year
so I'm fine with them recasting the role
but I know a lot of you are still like
well wait a minute if they have Colton
on arrow and they have this other Roy
Harper on Titan's how's that gonna work
out with at the same time well if you
remember Colton Haynes does not go on
arrow that often they make references to
Roy every once in a while so if they're
not gonna be using the character because
he is a core Teen Titans character I am
totally fine with titans recasting and
doing another version of that as long as
it ends up being awesome I think
everybody will be fine with it
part of the other reason for recasting
the role is if the show goes for like
seven seasons they don't want like a
thirty five thirty eight-year-old Colton
Haynes he's like in his late 20s right
now so he's not that old but you get the
idea like they don't want a really old
Roy Harper by the time they get to the
end of the show so they want somebody
that can grow with the rest of the
characters but the next big comic book
character sounds like it's gonna be
Elastigirl it says female 20s to 30s
Caucasian small-town Midwestern girl
gone to Hollywood Jennifer is a star on
the rise she comes across as doe-eyed
all-american and naive in her approach
to art and life jennifer emulates the
classic girl next door actors from the
1940s and 50s a bit like she's from
Stepford Wives in her thinking in
appearance Jennifer feels like a woman
out of time so instantly I was like wait
a minute are they casting a time
traveler like Legion of super-heroes
style no it's more likely that they're
casting Elastigirl who is an actress in
the comics or she was formerly an
actress before she became a superhero
she debuted during a teen titans story
so she's like a core Titans character
anybody that debuted in a teen titans
comic book is fair game for the Titans
showed to do so that's probably the
characters that they'll be focusing on
so when you're wondering about
characters that they cast just think
about teen titans characters but if you
guys saw last night's episode of the
flash with the elongated man think about
it that way like that's how they
accomplish powers like that so elastic
girl elongated man relatively
similar powers but then the next
character is supposed to be females 40
Caucasian forever sleepless with the
worry she's the mother to a young
troubled teen seeking a recognizable
cameo face or name so this one is a
relatively minor appearance of a pretty
big character because it's supposed to
be Ravens mother so they're looking for
like a really big actress to be like oh
my god you were impregnated with the
seed of Trigon how did that work out
there's a big Rosemary's Baby story in
there somewhere but she was part of a
cult the cult is the one that worshiped
Trigon that they wanted to bring into
this world so that's how you get to
Raven because she's like the vessel for
Trigon to come into our world so of
course it wouldn't be a Titans TV show
if they weren't gonna deal with Ravens
back story and Trigon eventually I'm not
expecting him to be the villain of
season one it's a little too soon to go
to him that big a villain that huge
maybe season 2 season 3 we'll see but I
wouldn't be surprised if they tease the
cult that's trying to track Raven down
so that they can bring Trigon to this
world and the cult itself is more of a
villain the first season but then
speaking of cult you have the cult of
blood brother blood it sounds like
they're casting him for the TV show too
which makes sense because he is a huge
Titans character so it says open
ethnicity age 50s to 60s so an older man
outwardly a warm kind presence he
doesn't seem the type to be powerful or
malicious but he has the ability to turn
on a dime and be the most terrifying man
you've ever met recurring guest star so
it sounds like they're setting brother
blood up to be a relatively
behind-the-scenes presence in season one
but then a much bigger deal in future
seasons as they push into Trigon
territory but now moving into Wally West
territory on the flash so he just left
that TV show a lot of people are like is
that because he's going to Titans so
this is what's going on with him this
season I can't say anything for what's
gonna happen with him next season but
part of the reason why the producers
said that they made him leave the show
for a couple episodes is because there's
way too many speedsters it's expensive
it's hard to handle him from a story
perspective because in order for Wally
to save the day you have to think of a
reason for Barry to not save the day and
he literally just came out of the Speed
Force four times more powerful than when
he went in
so if he's that powerful then why would
he need help from Wally so it just
there's a lot of logic problems so it's
much easier just to put him on the
sidelines for a couple weeks while you
introduce new characters like the
elongated man then you bring Wally back
when the threat level rises to the point
where you actually do need two
speedsters to help out but he's still a
main character on the flash TV show
that's not gonna change anytime soon so
if Wally goes to Titans it's probably
not going to be till season to it
whereas it seems like they're recasting
Roy Harper for Titans I think that they
would actually stick with Kenyon
Lonsdale for Wally West because he's so
young and it seems like he's so eager to
play the character and they've really
only scratched the surface with him so
it's almost like Worf being on
next-generation
and then going to Deep Space nine and
becoming a much bigger character like
they're actually getting to develop him
in a way that they didn't have time for
on next-gen because there were so many
other bigger characters they haven't
announced a release date yet I'm
expecting because they're gonna be
filming all the way up until like May
next year they're probably not gonna
start dropping episodes at least til the
summer or the fall but they're also
dropping Young Justice season 3 on that
DC streaming service that might wind up
dropping during the summer because
they're doing like 23 to 26 episodes of
that but they still haven't announced
when they're gonna start premiering
episodes so I think they're just trying
to figure out logistics and making sure
that they have enough episodes in the
can to start dropping them but it's
probably gonna be on a weekly basis the
way that they're dropping one episode of
Star Trek or the way that HBO does
episodes on its HBO now streaming
service but when we get new information
about that I'll post new videos so don't
worry too much about that right now
there is a new round of that blast ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
congratulations to the winner from the
last video de coria Kanzler I think I'm
pronouncing your name right and I still
get lots of questions about the flash
ring I think it's from mostly younger
people that just don't understand the
logic of buying stuff online flash rings
are purchased online and then sent to
winners but because I need to pick from
random comments I can't pick people that
say give me the flash ring because then
automatically it becomes a non-random
thing so if you do want to enter flash
ring giveaway sand this is really the
same thing for all the giveaways that I
do
just make sure the comment that you
leave to enter yourself has nothing to
do with winning the giveaway just has to
be a random comment about whatever's
happening in the video that's it really
simple but click here for a brand new
flash footage and you can click here for
brand new Justice League thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight